doug mcgregor is in some ways at the
center of this story he's retired army
colonel who last year advised the trump
administration on foreign policy in that
capacity he co-authored a memo calling
for american troops to leave afghanistan
finally after 20 years
according to woodward and costa's
account that memo mcgregor's memo is one
of the reasons that mark milley decided
to organize a coup
doug mcgregor joins us in studio tonight
doug thanks so much for coming on
um we were talking before air and you
upsettingly did not seem shocked by this
it does seem to people who don't know
the system as well as you do stunning
that the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff would be secretly calling a
chinese general and saying we'll warn
you if we're going to move against you
but
knowing what you know this does not
shock you
no unfortunately i'm not shocked keep in
mind we have yet to hear from general
milley yes we're accepting what bob
woodward wrote in the book
effectively gospel truth
and i'm not doubting woodward's
integrity but we know from experience
that from time to time he's somewhat
flexible and the interpretation may put
a spin on it that that may or may not be
accurate and i hope this is one of those
cases but the
milli has not responded as of
807 eastern
so
the fact is that the claim is that he
made this phone call to his counterpart
in the chinese military and did not tell
the president the former president has
issued a statement suggesting that he
did not know
so that alone
tell us is this with inbounds or is it
as far out of bounds as it seems no
there are certain things that we know
these are the facts first of all the
chairman of the joint chiefs has no
statutory authority over operational
forces of any kind
that means that he is not in a position
to order anyone in the armed forces to
say or do anything he can't do it he is
preeminently the senior military adviser
to the president
that's what he is so in theory before he
would make such a phone call he would
discuss the subject of the phone call
with the president the
commander-in-chief he certainly would
not do something without coordinating
with the national security adviser and
the secretary of state because this is
beyond defense this is a foreign policy
statement that he's making
these are important things to understand
the third thing and this is so if that
is true if this account is correct
i mean this is
from a layman's perspective it sounds
like a grave offense yes he's violated
the law if this turns out to be true we
really need to hear from him congress
needs to bring him over he needs to be
placed under oath and he needs to answer
questions in front of the senate about
this entire affair needs to be very
straightforward they they then will have
to determine whether or not the law has
been broken but from our standpoint
knowing what we do about who has the
authority to do what and where he fits
in within the broad scheme of things
this is wrong remember the president is
not
able to act independently and launch a
nuclear weapon he has a consultative
process people who are members of a
standing committee with whom this is
this is discussed this chain of command
that runs through the secretary of
defense and from the secretary of
defense to strategic command stratcom
has nothing to do with general milley
now general milley as an advisor can
speak up and suggest what they should or
shouldn't do but i think there's
something else here that people need to
understand if general milly feels as
strongly as he apparently does according
to this description about president
trump
he has at any time the right to resign
his position as chairman of the joint
chiefs and simply say i cannot be part
of this without prejudice that doesn't
mean he has to leave the armed forces it
just means he leaves this position and
someone else can be brought in to fill
it that's what you do if you feel
strongly that you're dealing with
someone you cannot support well millie i
i'll just make this call because it's
very obvious he's a dishonorable man um
we know that from his testimony before
congress i think it's very clear
on the other hand you know we we know
for a fact that he was speaking
in his
capacity i guess as a part of political
partisan to the leaders of the other
party yes that is true colluding against
trump on a political and a partisan
level he made it very clear on numerous
occasions that he was talking directly
to
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
and senator chuck schumer reassuring
them that he quote unquote was in
control of things in the pentagon there
are plenty of people that saw that
including the acting secretary of
defense
that's unfortunate that seems so corrupt
well it seems corrupt and again this
sort of suggests to me this is another
windsock this man blows with the wind
clearly the wind was moving left and he
was cultivating his bosses that much i
could accept without hesitation
is just the entire narrative i would
like to have that examined and explored
under oath in the right setting i gotta
say
maybe the the most profound casualty
here is the faith that people have that
our system works and that their views
are represented in the way the country
is run that's the most basic promise of
democracy and it seems time and again
that we are learning in these details
that the opinions of the people who live
here and pay for it all have no bearing
on anything look i think it's very clear
that the american people are not
represented widely in washington d.c
it's occupied territory ralph nader used
to call washington occupied territory
was occupied by corporations it's
occupied and controlled by donors
so the american people aren't asked very
much of anything about anything whether
it's immigration
going to war intervening somewhere
militarily none of those things are done
so we know that that's already a huge
problem
i just want to make one point very clear
though yeah president trump is not
someone who is prepared to launch a
nuclear strike out of the blue against
anyone right i'm just trying to
certainly
it's the whole thing is bs actually
trump was the first president since
jimmy carter who didn't launch a war
so right yeah the whole thing is a lie
a lot of things are lies we're learning
doug mcgregor thank you you'll see her
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else